Speaker 1: I want to look today at some really
great work being done by our friend Jesse
Dallimore.
Some of you might remember last summer Jesse
filled in for me when I was away, and he actually
went down to the Supreme Court yesterday and
spoke to a variety of different demonstrators
and activists and protesters.
And, you know, I'm kind of using all these
different terms because it was a combination
of different types of folks.
And I want to look at a couple of conversations.
He had.
The first one starting with an anti-choice
protester who seemed to have been hesitant
to really identify who he was with.
It's a very interesting and cringeworthy conversation.
So let's start there.
Jesse doing a really good job and you can
check out his YouTube channel podcast.
Let's just jump right into this first interview
that he did.
These are the types of folks that we are up
against here and understand that they don't
care about double standards, they don't care
about hypocrisy.
They care about only the outcomes, and they'll
justify anything to get to those outcomes.
Speaker 4: What's your name?
Colton.
What?
What are you doing out here today?
I'm going to be out here doing interviews
just like you about this as soon as my camera
guy gets here.
But I believe that the sanctity of life should
be protected and the Supreme Court shouldn't
be politicized.
And the fact that this opinion was released
with the leak is the issue, not the ruling.
I'm okay with the ruling, but the leak that
comes out so early, that just shows how politicized
this is.
Did you know that the original ROE ruling
was also leaked in 1973, which overturned
a few justices opinions?
So there was.
Speaker 1: It's like Jesse's visibly flummoxed
because the guy doesn't even seem to realize
the double standard.
Well, I'm concerned with the leak while Roe
v Wade in 73 also leaked.
Right.
Yeah.
But that overturned justices opinions, too.
But so what?
Huh?
Speaker 4: If this happens time after time
after time in the annals of the Supreme Court
and the history of the Supreme Court, why
is this?
Why is it such an outrage?
Not because they're trying to intimidate the
justices to overturn their opinions.
How how does it equate?
How does it map on to intimidation of the
justices by the public opinion threatening
the lies?
Last night they were out here chanting F Alito.
Speaker 1: This thing about the lives of the
justices are being threatened.
It's so absurd.
Supreme Court justices have great security.
The Supreme Court has great security.
No, nobody's life is in jeopardy here.
Speaker 4: Are you are you witnessing the
same thing?
I am relative to what is aggressive to serve
her in a crisis.
And we are witnessing and the power of prayer
vigils and speeches.
You know, we're getting ready to slug it out
here and that we have the majority of the
people who are pro-choice around death row.
Speaker 1: This kid's just very confused.
It's I mean.
Speaker 4: We wait.
Has got to go together.
Pro-Choice.
Well, the majority of the people on this side
is pro-choice.
Yes.
There are some pro-life people over there.
Who do you work for?
I'm not going to say.
You're not going to say.
Okay, so why was it you ditched the the the
proud boy motif when when I ask and ask questions.
Proud boy.
Yeah.
You know, they have the whole.
Well thing you got going on now the Project
Veritas hat.
Yeah.
Not, not proud fascist enabler.
No.
Really.
You want to your inner and you're in agreement
with stripping 50 years of precedent and human
and civil rights of women.
I am agreeing with protecting the life of
the unborn, which murdered over 63 million
unborn children.
So are you for the child tax credit?
I am for are you for the child tax credits
or.
This is a completely different.
Are you for increased SNAP benefits?
It's a completely different argument.
Speaker 1: It's kind of not, actually.
I mean, this is one of the big things.
Authoritarian clamp down on medical choices,
but then absolutely ignoring what should be
a responsibility once you force someone to
have a child.
Speaker 4: Because if 80,000 people are born
into poverty argument, how do you how are
you going to fund.
Are you mad to increase her industry that
cancer industry, the organizations that fight
against cancer, are you against them because
they don't fight against diabetes?
No, there's no there are two saying it's cause
and effect.
Speaker 1: Right.
But the thing is, fighting cancer doesn't
cause diabetes.
Fighting diabetes doesn't cause cancer that
I'm aware of.
So really good job by Jesse here exposing
this guy.
And then here's another one.
And this is just an example, again, of the
sort of like people that are ancillary and
attached to this anti-choice movement.
Speaker 2: Let's begin.
Speaker 1: So first, this is a guy I'm going
to try to see what it's.
Sure.
I want to describe to you what his shirt actually
says, because it's kind.
Speaker 4: The laws are worse than Jesse's
hand.
Speaker 1: It seems to be saying gay, bisexual
or transgender morals something than animals.
The National Zoo.
This is this is very weaponised stuff.
Speaker 4: I think National Zoo.
In 1991.
In 1990.
These girls went to school with these girls
in school.
You did not give.
You that they have any homosexual national
issues that important.
When you look at species of animals was got
out of the domestic body not that I'm a homosexual.
Well, if you come out here and everywhere.
Speaker 1: I guess this guy is saying there's
a it's a big red flag for him that a zoo didn't
have any gay animals.
But then he goes out goes out in the world
and there's gay people.
This is pretty deep stuff, guys.
Speaker 4: I want you to buy these two women,
of course, one in the miracle dog and their
dog like man.
So you can take no issue with wearing hate
speech on your shirt.
Or just about bigotry?
Hatred.
I said you're a bigot, right?
I. You are going to be a big hit telling people
like you.
Speaker 1: All right.
So the guy welcoming the label of a bigot,
really great stuff by Jesse and he speaks
to a number of different people.
I encourage you to check it out.
But again, it goes back to when we talk about
the big lie.
Trump really won 2020.
You go and you have a conversation with these
people and you realize these people, they're
gone.
To quote Alex Jones, how there's no bringing
them back.
And then on abortion, you go to the Supreme
Court, you talk to some of these folks and
you realize there's no bringing these people
back at at least not in any sensible, reasonable
amount of time.
Great job by Jesse.
We're really up against it here